un autre petit retour en 1988 pour
revenir sur le dernier jour du le
bimillénaire de strasbourg un binaire
qui s'est terminée on s'y attendait un
peu en chansons lui au travers de ses
chansons il s'agissait de faire un
dernier clin d'oeil au port aux plis le
fameux cabaret satirique de germain
muller quoi qu'il ne s'agissait pas non
plus pour le maître de cérémonie germain
muller 2 tout simplement s'autocélébrer
alors avec le philharmonique de
strasbourg avec roger siffer avec
l'ancien jacques martin et bien cette
soirée du réveillon a plutôt tenu de la
fête de famille une grande une très
grande famille puisque le palais des
congrès était comble françoise herbe
james petit et bruno girodon dinah faust
a mieux terminé l'année qu'elle ne
l'avait commencé je veux privé de bach à
vie pour cause de pied dans le plâtre il
ya quelques mois elle a fait revivre
samedi soir avec toute la troupe
quelques grands moments de l'histoire de
ce cabaret une fête de famille en somme
où tous les genres musicaux étaient
représentés qui dit grande scène du
grand orchestre le philharmonique de
strasbourg accompagné tous les artistes
lors de ce gala de la saint sylvestre
l'ultime manifestation du bimillénaire
au grand soulagement de germain muller
organisé une centaine de magistrats
c'est la dernière alors dans un sens
dans cette bi centenaire il avance sur
moi ce n'est pas dire qu'il soit
quant à
le
des amis avaient répondu présent fred
mella le soliste des compagnons de la
chanson que germain muller connaît
depuis plus de 40 ans et jacques martin
un ancien du barabli ses débuts sur
scène il les a faits dans ce cabaret à
la fin des années 50
c'est là qu'il a appris son métier ça a
été formidable
j'en garde un souvenir la preuve je
reviens 27 ans après trente ans après la
troupe a pas mal changé quand même non
non non non germain muller comment
comment vous le trouvez maintenant une
pareille pareil c'est la même ambiance
quand je retrouve pas tout le monde mais
ceux qui sont là reste 8 6 il ferait ou
faire dorer morizet
yang
à
yoyo jeanne dit que c'est tous le faire
j'ai participé pendant des années ont
repris et j'ai appris mon texte
phonétiquement je dois dire la vérité je
n'ai jamais compris l'alsacien je jouais
le français de l'intérieur
jalili plus oui je ne lis plus mon
accent alsacien
quelques semaines
une super
bon
aulas
oh
en grande forme aussi leur salaire de 45
ans j'aimais trimestre
germain muller qui aimerait qu'un nouvel
auteur prenne la relève
participeront au printemps prochain un
festival organisé par roger siffer qui a
dit que le bar habillé tes mains